é um prazer estar aqui uma boa tarde
meu nome é felipe fontes eu acho que eu
me classifico como empreendedor social
há uns três anos atrás eu resolvi criar
um sistema que ajudava pessoas próximas
é essa ajudar em situações emergenciais
a e formulação solução que teve
repercussão bem legal ganhou alguns
prêmios a e inclusive utilizado em
alguns governos como aplicação oficial
para chamadas emergenciais
ajuda muito populações de risco mulheres
protegidas lei maria da penha açude
multa que não conseguem fazer uma
ligação a maioria dessa história é que a
gente só conseguiu manter-se nesse
projeto de pé que era um projeto social
quando a gente se transformou numa
empresa de tecnologia prestando serviços
de tecnologia privada a empresa começará
com foco comercial a e privado
há uma história legal história diferente
mas é para chamar a atenção que alguns
caminhos são bastante difíceis a gente
teve que ter muita sorte muita gente
ajudando e foi difícil pra caramba
sobreviver num caminho então a sinuoso
é por isso que eu acredito que vocês
também tenham passado por esse tipo de
dilema ao longo de suas vidas é quais
caminhos seguir alguns caminhos nos
levam a lugares tão diferentes alguns
deles nos levam mais para a prosperidade
é ganhar dinheiro alguns outros já nos
levam a pra nossa auto realização sentir
que o nosso propósito tá sendo atendido
a o engraçado disso tudo é que são
caminhos completamente diferentes mas
eles são motivados pelo mesmo impulso
pelo nossa busca pela felicidade o tempo
todo a gente pode ter a a inclinação
política que foi o pensamento que for
as pessoas estão sendo motivados para
buscar sua felicidade
então é mais uma questão de estratégia
em quando algumas pessoas estão focando
mais no seu objetivo individual no curto
prazo
algumas outras pessoas estão pensando
como a atuar em questões globais ou
maiores que não vão ajudar só elas a ser
infeliz mas também outras pessoas a e
essa é uma questão legal de pensar é que
a gente pensa em
auto realização é a organização atua em
questões maiores não é só uma questão de
a dis se sentir bem a de de paz de
espírito ele tem um impacto real mesmo
se as pessoas juntas atua em questões
globais
elas vão conseguir fazer a diferença pra
todo mundo porque a nossa vida está
conectada à entrelaçado em questões
profundas violência urbana a meio
ambiente a e até a própria economia se
trata mal por outra pessoa com certeza
vai respingar em você também a então até
às vezes parece óbvio dizer aqui pra
gente ter uma vida mais feliz
o ideal é a gente tentar equilibrar
propósito a com prosperidade
o problema é que muita gente não tem
conseguido fazer isso
a maioria das pessoas está desencarnando
achando que não dá pra entrar pra seguir
dois caminhos têm que escolher um outro
eu mesmo larguei emprego larga carreira
até tentei abrir empresa ainda estou
sofrendo com esse com esse dilema a
gente tem onde saem até negócios sociais
mas de fato a gente ainda não descobriu
como sociedade uma forma eficiente de
engajar todo mundo numa construção de um
mundo melhor
assim que as pessoas tenham que sair do
seu caminho do seu dia a dia da sua
construção e felicidade pessoal e daí
que a gente tá no século 21
a nossa geração tem que enfrentar
desafios gigantes é é ruptura do sistema
previdenciário a automatização dos
empregos uma severa a degradação
ambiental continua o aumento da pobreza
e da diferença das rendas
aí a gente tem que ocupar até com um
guerra entre países né muita gente vê
que o cenário futuro é catastrófico
por outro lado a tecnologia que a gente
tem acesso hoje a abrir oportunidades
incríveis ea gente pode sim a aproveitar
esse momento que a gente vive e utilizar
a tecnologia a nosso favor
a pra fazer com que as pessoas consigam
atuar nas questões a que elas acreditam
e assim às vezes um mundo mais feliz pra
todo mundo
o negócio que não é só uma questão de
tecnologia também é uma questão de
pensamento de mais 7 a 1 hoje a gente
vive num sistema implacável a você errou
você pagou muito individual o que
acontece
as pessoas não percam com medo de errar
ninguém aqui todo mundo pode
tenho ideia mas ninguém sabe fala
realmente qual é o caminho certo a
seguir ou em que imprensa que cresceu
acreditar com o projeto eu vou acreditar
que as pessoas acabam desencadeando a
desacreditando porque elas têm medo de
errar como elas vão sofrer com aquilo e
é por isso que a gente precisa criar
processos para compartilhar o risco para
tolerar para criar um processo onde a
gente consegue sistemicamente testar
novas oportunidades sem estar se
sacrificando se está fazendo caminhos a
enviar individuais que a gente vai se
frustrar e acaba desistindo a eu eu por
exemplo colabora com uma iniciativa
experimental chamada cloud clapton
a gente usa todo o poder do
cooperativismo para criar novos negócios
a gente como se a gente investir em
novos negócios a e negócios normais a de
tecnologia startup ou tradicionais
a única diferença é que esse negócio de
propriedade coletiva ou seja no momento
que eles começarem a dar lucro eles vão
distribuir resultado para todo mundo
a longo prazo e isso gera uma
rentabilidade para muita gente a isso é
uma reflexão a de um pensamento que hoje
empreender é democrático você pode ser
um gênio se você não tiver acesso ao
recurso ou você vai vender sua casa e
vai correr muito risco ou você não vai
conseguir sair do lugar
e aí então a gente começa a achar
caminhos que a gente cria condições
econômicas mais igualitárias 100 perdeu
a meritocracia ou seja as pessoas estão
construindo a o seu futuro
ah eo próprio crouch capitu é uma um
pensamento experimental nessa cultura é
de experimentar coisas e que a gente
traz até uma uma provocação será que as
empresas socialmente sustentáveis de
verdade não são aquelas que estão
distribuindo sua riqueza com o maior
número de pessoas
muita gente fala que é socialmente
sustentável mas bocas famílias acumula
muita riqueza ea gente pode fazer
empresa sendo criadas justamente para
fazer as pessoas mais ricas
o crowd capitão só uma iniciativa assim
a em fase inicial
só que representa um conceito que está
se formando no mundo inteiro a gente
começa a ver realmente a união dessa
consciência coletiva com a liberdade
individual ou seja essa polarização que
a gente vê hoje no fim das contas é uma
armadilha existe um caminho que é o meio
termo que respeita a liberdade das
pessoas e que também trabalha
por causas maiores hoje por exemplo a
equipe a gente tem pessoas que têm
ideologia socialista trabalhando com
neoliberais
o que a gente achava que era impossível
e é possível sim se a gente foca nos
pontos comuns quer criar uma sociedade a
feliz e sustentável a esses caminhos
eles podem levar a gente muito a lei não
é só igualdade de renda mas também
crescimento a da economia quando a gente
permite que uma pessoa possa trabalhar
uma causa ela pode está ociosa e começa
a produzir trabalhar por mais coisas e
realmente trazer mais resultados da
economia a mais do que isso algumas
questões que são tabu hoje é que estão
longe podem ser começar começar a ser
discutidas por exemplo é renda básica
universal o consumo com 10 impacto
ambiental
esse tipo de coisa pode ser abordada por
esse tipo de oportunidade sem ter nenhum
conflito com a nossa economia hoje ou
seja não precisa de uma revolução tá
funcionando de acordo com economia mais
que isso sem nenhuma dependência de
governos ou estados
ou seja a gente tem tudo para conseguir
fazer grandes coisas acontecerem sem
depender das pessoas e é por isso que
estou bastante otimista que quando a
gente usa a tecnologia que já está
disponível com esse novo tipo de
pensamento as pessoas não vão precisar
mais escolher é entre prosperidade e
propósito e aí não vai restar nenhum
outro caminho que não seja a gente ser
feliz junto
muito obrigado gente num